you've probably heard the tour the term
short sale and have a at least a general
Oh what did I do with that there I did I
scroll down and you probably have a
general idea that it means to some
degree making a bet that a stock will
fall and there's been a lot of news
lately that maybe short sellers are to
blame for a lot of the stock market
crashes or what's happening with banks
so I thought it would be worthwhile to
at least explain what a short sale is
and then we could talk a little bit
about whether they're positive or
negative or they could be both so you
are right if you think that a short sale
is some type of a bet that a stock can
go down but how does it work so let's
say that I don't know IBM now know where
IBM is trading right now but let's say
IBM IBM is right now it's the last trade
was at $100 that's $100 and I'm
convinced I've done my research I've
done my analysis and I'm just convinced
that the stock price of IBM is going to
fall I think IBM is going to have a
horrible quarter next quarter that some
other competitor is going to take their
business whatever I'm convinced it's
going to fall to $50 right this is what
I think I think it's going to fall to
$50 based on my deep stock analysis and
so the general idea is that I should
well I won't make any value judgement
right now but I want to know if there is
a way that I can make money off of my
deep analysis and the way I do that is I
go to my brokerage so let me make draw
some diagrams so this is my brokerage
this is my broker and I mean this is me
right here this is me I have a top hat
anyway so I go to the broker and say
broker I would like to short IBM I would
like let's just say for for simplicity I
want to short one share of IBM so what I
do is I go to the broker and say broker
can I borrow a share of IBM and this is
a little unintuitive the first time
people learn about it it was a little on
to ative for me the first time I learned
about the notion of borrowing a share
but you could also view it as renting a
share and you might say well where's the
broker getting it from well this broker
has got a ton of clients
right let me draw some of them his eyes
were strange okay so this broker has a
ton of clients many of whom own IBM and
they keep their shares of IBM with the
broker so the brokers always has you
know all of let's say each of these as a
share of IBM and these guys are all
owners of IBM and if ever one day this
guy wanted to sell his share of IBM the
broker would go out there sell it in the
market er maybe this guy would sell it
depending on how it's done and then this
would be replaced with the money and
this would then become a hundred dollars
right and then if IBM issues a dividend
if it says okay all of our shareholders
will get five dollars from the companies
and then each of these guys would get
five dollars so they're all just
shareholders in the company and also
just so you know as opposed to being
short the company they're long when you
go long a security you're buying the
security when you go short as you'll see
you're borrowing the security and
selling it so let's see how that works
so once again I go to my broker and I
said broker I want to borrow a share of
IBM the broker says okay well you know I
have all these shares sitting down
sitting around here and they're really
not doing anything I'll lend you these
this share right there
and stick it in my account and I'm gonna
have to pay rent to borrow that share
you can kind of view it as either
interest on the on the you know on
borrowing the share you could view it as
rent rent is sometimes more intuitive
because whenever we talk about you know
when you when you rent someone's
apartment you're really kind of
borrowing their apartment and you can
kind of view the rent as the interest on
the apartment or the other way to view
it when you borrow money the interest is
kind of rent on the money right anyway I
think you get the ideas but I'll borrow
this and you'll say hey wait Sal that
doesn't make sense how can you just
borrow this guy stock right I mean this
guy might want to sell it the next day
and that's a good question if this guy
wants to let's say I borrow his stock so
it's not sitting there anymore if this
guy wants to sell his stock the second
after I borrow it the broker is just
going to take he's just going to shuffle
around the stocks a little bit I mean
you know stocks are they call it
fungible you can replace one stock
certificate with the other they're no
different so then he'll say okay
give this stock to this guy a whoops
it's messed up with my pen I'll just
give this stock to the guy who wants to
sell it and then you would have
essentially borrowed from this guy and
you could keep rearranging the security
so that none of these guys ever know
that their stock is borrowed although
you have to give permission especially
if these guys own the stock outright
they have to give permission to let the
stock be borrowed and they benefit
because they get some cut hopefully they
get some cut of the rent or the interest
that I'm paying so it's you know it's
beneficial to them and the broker you
know the broker can never well it should
never really lend out all of the shares
here just so that it can keep shuffling
around and we'll talk about what happens
if you actually try to do this with a
share that you've never borrowed we'll
do that in a future thing but the
general idea is you borrow one of these
shares out here and then the broker can
kind of keep shuffling around these
shares if any of these guys really want
to get rid of their share and let's say
I've borrowed this guy's let's say you
know I originally borrowed this guy
share this guy wanted to sell his share
so that the broker does is he takes this
share gives it to him and now I have
officially borrowed this guy share right
this is the share I've borrowed now
because this one's been sold now what
happens if IBM issues a dividend it says
every one of our shareholders should get
five dollars well this guy is expecting
a $5 check right or he expects $5 to be
deposited in his brokerage account for
that to happen I essentially have to
write this guy the $5 check so I have to
make it look or at least a broker the
brokerage is going to force me to make
it look like this guy still owns the
sitch the share so anything that this
guy gets by being a shareholder of this
stock I have to provide for him anyway
so I borrowed the stock now what do I do
with it my whole thesis here is that IBM
is going to $50 so how do I make money
off of that so I said it's trading right
now at $100 I've borrowed this share
I've borrowed the share so I sell it so
let's see the first thing as I borrow
borrow one share as I've done there and
now I sell it on the market and we said
it's selling for $100
I sell it for $100 so I sell it to the
market so I sell let's say the market is
out here to the left so I sell to the
market and I get $100 so let's see
what's happening right now I have what's
my current state of affairs say assets
and I'll talk about margin requirements
later liabilities what do I have what do
I owe so now I have $100 and what do I
owe I owe one share of IBM let's say my
analysis ends up being correct
oftentimes it won't and we'll talk a
little bit more about why short selling
can be extremely risky but let's say my
analysis is correct and a couple of days
later IBM starts trading at $50 what I
can do now is unwind my trade or cover
my short and the way I do this is I have
$100 right what I can do is I can then
just go out there and buy my shares of
IBM back right so I buy one share of IBM
and how much do I have to pay I'd have
to pay $100 well no the share of IBM
stock prices dropped to $50 so actually
let me do that I'm not paying $100 out
I'm going to pay $50 out I'm going to
pay $50 and I'm going to get back a
share of IBM I'm going to get back a
share of IBM and that's what I owe so
I'll give it I'll give it back to my
brokerage so I will see I will go out
spend 50 get back a share and then give
that share back to the brokerage and
give it back to that guy these guys
never knew that anything happened and in
the process what happened I sold the
shares for $100 and I bought them back
for 50 so after unwinding this whole
thing I use 50 of this hundred to buy
the shares back so how much do I have
left I have $50 left and $50 left and I
return the shares of IBM so I have
nothing I don't won anything so I made
$50 off of this trade so traditionally
in the stock market on the long side you
want to buy low sell
right you want to buy low sell high sell
high when your short selling you're
doing it you're doing the same thing but
you're doing in Reverse you want to sell
high sell high and buy low anyway
hopefully that gives you the general
idea of the mechanics of short selling
in the next video I'll talk a little bit
of more about what you know this was a
very good scenario where it happened
what what I wanted to happen did happen
but in the next video we'll talk about
the risks of short selling and maybe a
little bit of a discussion of whether it
really is good or bad for the markets or
for society as a whole
see you in the next video